let me ask you something bro what's up
man how about my how about my cardigan
bro how about my hold on what why'd you
go you didn't is that old do you just
find it like like in your closet or
something yeah I knew that you could
tell right mhm you're looking at you're
studying it like looks like it's inside
out no you know what you're looking
you're looking at it like um somebody
just laid a rug and you're looking at
whether or not goes with the couch I
don't know how to take I know how to
take it in obviously don't wear a v-neck
ever never wear with a cardigan not
these days unless your name David
Beckham and the other thing is I got I
got a build orange like track Sho they
were given to me by by New Balance and
because I'm athletic they definitely
weren't I know the guys that new
balances they send me shoes no one sent
you those I believe someone New Balance
didn't send you those yes well someone
maybe from a store it was from store but
I also remember when you bought them no
I didn't buy these these were actually
given to me they yeah they came in a box
yeah I know with some other stuff not
from New Balance though maybe not from
newal I don't think they're like I don't
think they're like we need the 50 you
know what it was it was Rob Rob Green
World our publicist sent me a Bo sent us
a box that stuff yes came in there yeah
New Balance armor has no idea who it's
going to they're just trying to they
were trying to get rid of these is what
they were trying to do CU they thought
nobody would wear hot pink running shoes
but but then I'm 50 but like if you wear
them to run in I I can understand that
but you have business socks on yeah I do
have business socks with a Bill Cosby
cardigan I'm going to take this off
right now it's a little hot to begin
with no I like it man I do too but I'm a
little hot
I'm a little hot were you just like
going through your closet or like sure
[__] it sure was because you know I only
have I only have those cashmere sweaters
from it's too hot right too hot so now
I'm left with nothing but t-shirts I got
to set my clothing game up we've talked
about this but I just tend to gravitate
toward the same [__] over and over you
could have wore the boots I got you how
nice are those boots well those boots
are amazing and what I'm doing is I'm
going to wear them around the house to
make sure sure that they're the perfect
size they're not GI know what tooot is
they're not Brennon bought me a pair of
to boots they ain't giving them away
they're not giving those boots away
especially I've seen you should wear
them in Austin that's why I bought them
for on stage especially when you break
them in not only that cuz they're rubber
they have that rubber so so that get
great traction the insides that's why I
love to boots oh [__] now now here's the
other thing I I was going to I was going
to take them back to where you got them
so I can see if there are other toots
that maybe are you know even more I
don't know I want to see what the cuz
they're so expensive I want to see what
the uh selection is oh so you don't like
them I love them oh no you don't like
them I swear to God I love them then why
would you want to take them back to see
what else they have just because I know
how expensive they are and I'm like well
these are great but I wonder if there's
one that's even more rugged than these
cuz they look they're so nice I'm afraid
to scuff them
up I bought those for a reason because
the ones you wear now yeah look at me
they're terrible cuz they're all scuffed
up yeah so these you could wear on stage
so people take you serious so they look
CU if if you walk in with those or the
old boots you have I'm thinking myself
this guy don't have a whole lot going on
yeah well comic I know comic I love this
look I love the boots like like even
Rogan step again Rogan wears the
varvados cons now yeah
I I love the boots I sent brenon a
picture when he sent me those I sent him
picture of a tiger in tall grass with a
caption Brendan waiting to see if I'll
wear his incredibly expensive
those I think they' be good for you to
step your game I love I swear to God I
love them and I can't believe how
comfortable they are I'll be all over
don't take those just leave them in your
closet don't take them back for a
different boot no I would take them back
for a different to boot
boot I wouldn't I I wouldn't I think
your tast is great I just they're they
listen I'm not going to take them back
the truth is I'm waiting to see if
they're I haven't worn them enough
around the house to make sure they fit
my foot perfectly I don't want those was
that why won't you just wear them today
I don't want to scuff them on on the
round INE no in case I have to get a
size bigger that's all I have size bger
I think I'm I think I'm perfect but I
want to make sure what they said yeah
they're nice so I told what size you
wear and they're like then you need to
wear get them this yeah to boot to
booties um you're wearing a pair of uh
Gucci loafers which of course they're
not giving away they've got the they got
a tiger on them most comfortable shoe I
own I don't care but they have tiger on
them I will admit that they do go with
the pants yeah they're pretty cool oh
you talking about the junk theme I'm
talking about the jungle theme I look
like a Jungle Book theme today you you
look like you belong in you is your name
moley will I get booed off the stage
tonight at the laugh Factor if I dress
like this it might be a distraction no
you won't you know why because you're
you have cauliflower ear and you're a
giant and you've earned it I have not
earned it no no no you've earned you've
earned you've earned the ability to
dress like candy ear like an [__]
well you're not an [__] you you you
can't help yourself you love fashion
which I admire uh but you are um you're
big and tough enough to get away with
wearing [__] that most people would get
punched in the face
for okay cuz you decorate you decorate
you're bit of a peacock and let me take
a bit out of that word your peacock your
peacock think these are your man peacock
okay your man peacock and I actually
like them on you thanks man I don't
approve of how much they are but I do
like them on you you get away with it I
well I wish I could say the same I do
not like those running sh I don't blame
you and I wear them if you start running
I'm down I wear them because I are you
still working out that uh barbell Club
place I'm gonna I have a I have my
lesson my weightlifting lesson today at
4 dude but I'll tell you something right
now it's just a oneon-one with you in
this just Juice Head or what uhhuh and
he's an Olympic weightlifter uh and he
was on the alternate team but I'm not
going to do any as much I'm not going to
go deep this time because guess what
deep squats cause my knee to act up and
my hip to act up I know why you're doing
it which is which is the first thing you
said is that's how guys get injured so I
don't I just don't get you just want to
be in shape right like to feel healthy I
just wanted to mix it up and I was like
let me see what this is about that's
fair yeah you know but it's a lot of
technique and it's not easy and I'm not
sure I care enough I was uh working out
this morning at boxen bur in uh Santa
Monica oh and they have a uh uh box and
cocation at extreme coutur in Las Vegas
coming up go to I think it's box andb
burn.com or just the boxing burn
Instagram you'll find them but Tony Jeff
Glenn they extreme coutur in Vegas for
the best and certification uh hands down
anyways I'm there in Santa Monica uh
with my trainer working out we're doing
some crazy pullup thing and's I don't
know why I'm laughing and there's a guy
on a motorcycle and there's bad traffic
in kou goes over the top of the car I
just see it all oh boy everyone saw it
was he all right I don't know he seemed
all right he like laid on the car for a
lit and was just shaking his head but
what was weird is something must have
been going on because the guy who hit
him in a in a Cadillac yeah I don't know
what's going on
because the cops might have been falling
or something because they were feds I
didn't closed in on along with cops it
wasn't like just because the biker
there's paramedics no they're like feds
yeah so I was like what is going maybe
he was trying to get away something was
going on here here's the thing here hey
something's going on and I'm a I'm a
Snoopy snooper uhhuh almost ruined my
workout cuz I wanted to investigate I
watched so much First 48 you know I
watched last night and people a lot of
people forget about this remember the
Mendes Brothers in Beverly Hills that
killed their parents sure do and
reloaded their gun that's where the jury
said that didn't over no no I thought
the same thing cuz uh I was [__] I was
seven when that was going on I think
yeah uh I was like 1990 yeah but um so
the Mendes Brothers family was rich the
the two they're twins right well I think
they were Twins or they were brother
they're just brothers Brothers
uh they want the parents' money so they
come in with shotguns into the room
blast both the parents the moms walk on
the ground the brother reloads shoots
the mom in the face good God they go to
court what so you gave birth to two
sociopaths so they they inherited $14
million right inherited $4 million they
said in a month they spent over a
million dollars they're just going nuts
in a mon and people like hold up if you
killed your or your parents died it
wouldn't be celebrating like this so I 6
months later they get brought in then
you know what their their plea was you
know what insanity or sexual abuse from
their father they said their father and
they they would cry on the stand and so
it was a hung jury some people were like
no these guys are sociopaths other
people like God they got molested you
know they they were destroyed their
their entire lives and so they had gave
horrible accounts of their father
molesting him and all this stuff and
then uh the OJ Simpson thing happened so
the LA District Attorney office is
pissed because they keep losing cases
this one was a hung jury obviously the
OJ Simpson think [__] them so so this
guy's like no [__] this we're we're re
we're going to do a retrial and then
they tried playing you know that they
were sexed again all that stuff and it
didn't hold up in court right but also
the prosecution knew exactly what they
going to do and
just destroyed them there's no evidence
of it imagine what kind of scumbags
these are a you kill your parents then B
you drag his name through the mud and
say he was sexually molesting you and
gave Vivid account of him raping you and
you sucking his dick and him taking uh
needles to your dick and your ass like
horrible things and then they would cry
but they said in the they would go in
the back and after they were done giving
their uh testimonies they would highfive
each other like they would do such a
good job you know when you're that age
your frontal cortex your decision making
part of your brain is not fully
developed I get that no I'm saying I'm
saying when you're a criminal like that
you you're you're so impulsive at that
age that you're yeah yeah no you're
missing my
you're missing my point you're missing
my point my point is that they thought
they could get away with it but they
don't think things through so if you're
a sociopath at that age your frontal
cortex is not built so you give your
testimony then you come back and you
high five like an idiot or you spend a
million dollars in a month without
thinking like planning ahead they got
away with it for for six months the only
reason they got caught they it was
almost the perfect murder they actually
did a really good job there's just a few
things that got him to hi up they
actually did a really good job not John
Benet family style that that could job
but they did a [__] think about they
didn't have [__] for six months on them
right until things started to come on
like those detectives started putting
two and two together when there's no
they can't find any leads no Breakin all
that weird stuff they're like wait a
minute this doesn't make sense it so
brutal you gave birth to two sociopaths
isn't that funny we talk about terrorism
and all that and you could just give
birth to Bad Seeds they told you what I
went to the expert who interviewed him
said the one brother was saying how
loving his parents were his dad and mom
the other one was just like not having
it so I think the other one really
influenced one of them yeah but they I
told you when I was at school we went to
this child psychologist for all the
parents you know just to talk about
parenting and maybe we had some
questions and she was an expert and she
said uh somebody was asking question and
question and she said look look I I'm
going to say this and uh you know people
won't say this but some of you may have
given birth to an unlikable child it
happens I've seen it and it's just the
way it is you can give birth to a bad
seed when I you can also make a bad seed
you can make a bad seed too but those
some people are born so they're they
there's a lot of science to suggest to
point to the fact that some people are
born bad they're born bad but then
there's also experience that turn them
bad oh yeah oh yeah for them too they
they were having issues with their
father with money issues and and stuff
like that and they they thought they're
going to get this huge lump of money and
their dad's like nah [__] you guys
you're a losers you're not getting
anymore so there's certain events that
caused them to lead up to this they were
[__] to begin with probably yeah
tools God damn God dang it's really
interesting yeah and what's crazy is
they were sitting in the LA County jail
and uh they're watching on TV the OJ
Simpson uh you know his chase down the
405 obviously they caught him at his
Brentwood home and then they said uh
they're watched them then hours later
they see OJ Simpson walk by handcuffs
and they put him right next to one of
the brothers no really so the you know
those brothers and then Lang talk tells
a story about LA County J when he got
arrested for basically doing below
throwing fruit at Pavilions as my
manager we had the same manager was
throw fruit at him oh yeah my manager
kenish was trying to stop him but he was
throwing fruit at at Ken and then uh
they then he's standing there and the
cop is like you got to calm down right
now you know drop the fruit or whatever
and AR was like all right drops the
fruit and pulls out a tiny spoon and
just starts doing blow right in front of
the cop the cop's like all right that's
it oh to get ARR then they handcuffed
him to a gang member who was uh had stab
wounds in his back and he spent like you
know 15 hours in LA county jail like
standing in line to get processed and
stuff it was the worst thing work coming
down from cocaine and they recognized
him from a sketch he used to do called
my white mama where Arty BEC AR already
takes on the soul of a black woman a a
big black woman and so he's like you my
you know and he was doing this thing and
it was called my white mom it was a huge
hit among especially among urban
populations I.E the black audience and
and and Latino audience and so it was
hilarious because they were like yo man
you make me laugh my mama is all these
like like essentially Latino drug guy I
mean gang guys yeah they loved him they
were like yo man do that thing and so's
like he's all [__] up he's like you're
my baby you like laughing and he's
chained to this dude he's like making
friends with him he said that's probably
the worst time this is one of the low
points of his life that's a bad time I
guess LA County Jail is just a [__]
hot God oh my God yeah I remember we
were shoot anyway I don't want to go
into it but there was some crazy [__]
that went
on have you ever been in jail not not
for shooting I'm talking about I've been
have you been arrested I sure have been
and I spent uh almost two days sleeping
on the floor where and holding court and
they called started to call me professor
cuz I was like trying to I can't
remember what I was doing you know me
old how old were you h i was uh 37 what
did you do I got in a fight really yeah
and they put you in jail uh yeah the
cops were watching it to see what these
guys were bothering C New York yeah it's
New York uh also got picked up for
talking to prostitutes I remember that
uh and they were cops and I did not
solicit prostitutes I did not solicit
one you're just going to talk to them no
I I literally they were these two hot
girls I swear to God this is so funny uh
um you told this story on the podcast
did I yeah okay never mind then no you
can keep going well was just that they
started talking to me I like didn't you
went to the ATM though well they said
how much I I said said do you have any
money on you I said I got $5,000 honey
joking around I was on my way home I
look I got no problem having sex with a
prostitute done it before in this case I
was not and uh I go to the ATM to get
money for a cab guess who's waiting for
me the cops I go I'm getting money for a
cab they go well sorry buddy you're
you're under arrest I was like a and the
girls a little too much sir you talk to
prostitutes then you go to get money for
the C yeah but they were in a car and I
was on my way home there's I would never
there's nowhere to go with them I was
going to take them to my parents house
there was no I wasn't going to go Hotel
yeah car and they weren't even that
goodl looking they they called me over
to the car so there was entrapment those
[__] and I'm like yeah hey talking
say I'm talking like this hey ladies and
I'm looking at them I want to look at
their legs and stuff like that and and I
could tell they were they were kind of
it was awkward and one of them was
skinny the main one talking to me I was
like not not attractive and I go across
the street to the ATM and they're
waiting for me these [__]
that's not that's not fair and I even
said to them I go they and the guy goes
you got caught up you got caught up in
the [__] in the sweep you got to CAU
in the sweep there's nothing we can do
and then I'm sitting next to this poor
guy who was dressed like a woman he was
this guy and they were telling him to to
take his uh nail polish off and he was
scraping the nail polish off and they
were calling him Tootsie and I got mad
at the cops I go guys [__] give him a
break man come on he's he why would they
take the CU dressed like a woman go to
jail they going to
you don't go like that take the nail
polish off and he was so nervous he was
this big fat guy probably in his 40s and
I said to him I go I start talking to me
because I like dressing up like AB broad
sometimes that's all I just like
dressing up like a broad I'm not gay I
just you know it's what I like to do
sometimes that's all and I was talking
to these hookers that's all nothing
wrong with that yeah he had his own
fetish he was a sweet guy probably a
Broken Man probably some probably had a
job he hated and he was just trying to
get out and feel alive and they these
you know New York cops are Irish Italian
Guys Macho dudes Puerto Rican guys Macho
muscular guys and you know they're
they're going to make fun of you they
were they were doing it like they they
they were like this they weren being
they were like together theyy Tootsie
hey tell Tootsie in there and he could
hear it and I could hear it and it was a
bummer and I and I I scolded them trying
to talk to them like guys they kind of
didn't well not making fun but tell them
to be like hey man you're you're going
to New York [__] jail let not dress
like a chick all the homies are going
try [__] your mouth they don't though
you're in the you're in the [__] you
you're when you're in the holding cell
like that you're waiting for to get
processed and then I saw this one dude
it was his third strike and he's talking
to his girl like Mommy remember they got
me man I'm telling you you got to tell
him that I was at home he like literally
I'm like oh Jesus Christ and then third
stri dude the detectives came and took
him out those hardcore detectives you
see those detectives and you're like oh
you guys have seen some [__] dead eyes
[__] around dead eyes they come in
you're in trouble oh yeah my my father
said that my father said that these guys
at when he worked at City Bank these
guys who were Bankers thought it was
really awesome to manipulate the
computers where they would get one cent
off of every check that was deposited
and so they had like millions of dollars
and my dad was in there my dad tough guy
Marine you know things he said he said
let me tell you something if you think
you can if you're just a civilian and
you think that you can kind of play
stoneface with cops like guys you know
real detectives like you think you can
like kind of I'm not talk to my lawyer
I'm not saying [__] these [__] cops
the he said these FBI guys were just
professionals you know they've seen it
all yeah and you're you're quaking in
your boots and you've embezzled I don't
know $3 million and you're just a
regular guy but a lot of time but when
it comes that point they have so many
facts and so many stories they kind of
know bit of the story when they come in
he said these so as soon as you go a
weird way they're like that never
happened they were crying so hard they
didn't even ask for their lawy like
sorry the is when I was a kid my dad he
never gave me any attention they're like
all right listen yeah yeah yeah shut the
[__] up and they just literally grow
like I'm a we know you're a good person
but you did this and that's why we want
to help you yes okay I will they act
like you're your friend help us help you
man there's a murder out there don't you
care about your friend like yeah then
tell us like really yes like when I
watched that first 4 there's a kid on
there he was 18 he got in a scuffle with
some grown man and the grown man uh in
front of his friends he embarrass him
cuz he goes to attack or like Jack this
grown man's groceries and you know it's
like an older guy too and the older guy
pushes him off and punches him he drops
back well he's a young dude so he's
embarrassed so he pulls out a gun the
guy's walking back in cuz the old man
like [__] this he goes back in like call
the cops and the kid comes in in front
of everyone just shoots him in the chest
but he said he meant to scare him yeah
and but the bullet hits him in the chest
they Rush the guy the hospital he dies
anyways they pick the kid up after they
track his girlfriend then they track him
down another County try getting away
they bring him back but they're inter
interviewing him and you just see it
hits him like he had not that he's not a
you know he's obviously a shitthead but
he's also 18 he like he was embarrassed
and he was like honestly I I I was G to
I was trying to fire at the ground just
to scare him because he punked me so bad
and I told my friends I didn't want to
get punked and he shot at the ground you
know he's [__] a kid so the gun pulls
up and hits guy in the chest and he's
they're talking to him and you see it
hits him like you're going away for your
life's over and they're literally you
can see it hits them and you're just
like oh my my God and he's calling his
mom you're like oh [__] A waking
nightmare [__] this what I worry about
with my son boys do stupid [__] they do
impulsive [__] hopefully not with guns
they drive too fast they punch people in
the face they they pick up a knife
there's a difference between being a a
kid being a young boy in America being a
complete [__] [__] it's also the
friends you hang out with I had friends
who were normal guys who goes hey we're
going to rob a jewelry store do you want
to do it with us and I was like I mean
what I was like well I'm listening cuz I
was an idiot I'm listening like maybe
it'd be a lot of money for the summer
and if nobody gets hurt I'll break in
the window and stuff like that meanwhile
I was like I was like hey what the [__]
wait no no no no I don't want to I don't
want to break into a [__] jewelry
store and R what no I mean I grew up
with a lot of Knuckleheads man as long
as you have a good head on your shoulder
I mean I never guys were doing horrible
things never ever entain it because the
the crew I hung out with you were busy
not even I'm busy I'm not an idiot yeah
even as a young kid it's like you you
know right and wrong you all I I did
some stupid [__] I never did anything to
hurt anyone never robbed anyone my
father would say that my father would
say listen to me you think before you do
dumb [__] just take a couple of minutes
to count the 10 I've always been pros
and K I'm like What's the pro I steal
this clone con I get C he kicked off
football team suspended probably not I
don't need the call no you don't you
always want to get even punching
somebody in the face people are
[__] and you want to do something I
still feel that at 50 but you know what
for what you got so much to lose
starting with I told you the the story
where I was almost getting a fight with
the guy he waits outside for me I have
to be in Dallas the next day I was like
this guy actually wants to fight I was
like oh no best case in knock him out
and then and best case scenario and then
I look awesome and then I get sued I get
arrested I don't make my date in Dallas
or but where's case scenario he might be
able to fight I'm not that mad anymore
he knocks my tooth out be yeah or some
[__] I got to go to the dentist or I get
arrested anyway my mouth is all bloody
and yeah it was the worst I said what
for what's the what did he do didn't
something yeah he was bothering my
friend and I said why don't you shut up
I'll be let's go and then he goes I'll
be waiting outside quietly dude I was
[__] come on I was 45 uh it's so I
don't get that ego stuff I don't all
right cool man well that's exactly what
it is it's ego and it's and it's not
wanting an [__] to rule the roost
Hees you know you want hey I'm the guy
in Justice I'm the Justice League over
here cuz he's a dick and then I said to
my funny Mike well dud I would have said
the same thing to mik I'm going to go
I'm going to go out there and fight I'm
going to go out there and fight but you
have to hold me back and not let me
fight so it looks like I'm awesome but I
can't fight and he's like he goes I'm
not going to even let you outside what
are you talking about you're not going
out there and the guy was out there
making a bunch of noise guess who rolls
up the police o they were like move on
yeah yeah my wife was pregnant my wife
my pregnant wife was there and the guy
was just being [__] in the club to
your friend he was heckling my buddy and
then he said to Jamie Kaylor my buddy
I'll punch you in the face and I go
you're gonna punch you in the face and
I've been watching this awesome
Jiu-Jitsu video and I wanted to try it
with a jacket yeah dude let me know how
that goes Jack blue belt on her hand let
me know how that go he wasn't he wasn't
he he wasn't a big guy didn't look like
a I don't give a [__] black belts in the
street have a hard time pulling [__]
well you've never seen me on a street
fight brother look at me in the eyes you
never seen me in a street fight in Santa
Monica on Main Street with everything to
lose and a pregnant wife she was like
she my wife was like what what who are
you what's going on I know what what's
going on yeah I was like I don't know
I'm an idiot idea I came to my senses I
came to my senses when he went outside I
was like I don't want I'm not mad real I
don't I'm not even mad anymore and I I'm
fight you want be friends with them plus
I'm not stretched stretched oh God you
got to think about these things I don't
know man you got to think of these
things you're not at all like that but
you can't do anything no I can even if I
didn't have these skills I wouldn't be I
I I never understood it it makes it's an
ego thing it's like insecurity thing I
think I guess we feel disrespective but
it's also a Justice thing I hate a a
bully okay hate bullies so let me think
so if that guy said that to your friend
and he did nothing and then you want to
fight that guy you think by fighting him
the next day he wakes up goes you know
what I got stop being bullied that's not
how I think no he just keeps on keep
that's not how I think about it um I
think if you're a bully and you get away
with it I want to be the one to punch
you in the face it makes me want to
punch somebody in the face so badly that
that I'll do it about but you're not
going to do it I've done it
before I have I've done it more than
five times in my life and I did it as an
adult not as an adult I'm sorry to say
and it's embarrassing not L I've not
since I've known not the past six years
no no no but why why don't I'm gonna let
you talk to my sister I I hate stories
about fighting I remember I remember the
French story I remember all that there
are more stories than that my friend
I'll let let I'll let my sister who was
just three well let her explain to you
it all had to do with feeling as though
there was an injustice being in a
position where I felt like I could do
something that's exactly want be a mod
day superhero have you seen my standup I
know I mean look you're lucky you didn't
catch the right guy there's some guys
who are bullies that are like you
bullies I don't think you're going to do
[__] with an actual like tough guy well
well a Hell's Angel there's some bullies
look at me well you're not throwing a a
peep their way neither am I you're damn
right buling keep bullying however
however you got to also remember
something else about me that's kind of
sick I plan for that too and you know
what I mean by that I Believe In A
Sucker Punch I believe in a headbutt let
me know how that suun goes against the
Hell's Angels that would be very scary
that would be scary that would be not
scary terrifying because you know you're
going to go down right you know you're
in trouble it was like in uh it makes no
sense when I was dating somebody you
know um in New York and a 6'4 blonde
very handsome Hell's Angel was talking
to her and and he was clearly had
designs on her and I'm sorry and she
admitted it later she was a little
attracted to him as well she should have
been cuz he was an outlaw he was an
outlaw and a stud he was about six4 of
blond hair and I remember telling Chuck
Zito the story when I was doing Oz and I
said and I and I knew I'd get my ass
kicked but I knew that I as a man I
would have to stand up to him and uh but
I I take a beating and Chuck zto goes
yeah you definitely would have you
definitely would have you know you don't
get you become a Hell's Angel nothing
you don't get that I guess to yourself
that you didn't get punked you know what
I'm saying but like girl is not going to
be like oh thank God this guy was
hitting on me and Brian just oh he
ferociously attacked him and then got
his ass whooped in front of everybody
dude I'm I was a high school wrestler
but here's the thing also also what's
Chuck Zito doing these days I saw him
he's not in Hell anymore cuz he was in
he was on Sons of Anarchy he was like a
liaison they was in some of the episodes
yes he uh I saw him and had a long
conversation with him with Dove David
off at the Rainbow Room on Sunset and
how long ago it great he's such a he's
such a nice
guy um it was probably three years ago
now yeah huge hands he couldn't be more
muscular he used to always go to the
UFC's and I something happened there was
a falling out between him and Dana I
think maybe maybe he was like asking for
tickets I forget I don't know remember
he was always around yeah uh those guys
are um but but I remember I remember I
would see those guys those Hell's Angels
guys at the a place called The Edge
which was a bar in New York and again as
a man you look at these dudes and I
don't know what it is about the Hell's
Angels but they're they're good-look
dudes like they they they're these big
guys with the long hair they look with
the mustache the beard and you're like
and they just look and they're they're I
remember just some guy who was like me
started talking to one of them and I I
didn't want to approach any of them
because you know and I said what were
you talking about he because I was just
asking him about the club guy was a nice
guy but um yeah I I remember I remember
watching this guy talk to him my
girlfriend and kind of going well um at
this point he's a silver back and I'm a
baboon and I'm going to I'm going to
defer when the lion see when the
Jackal could you take your girl and just
walk away oh no no she was in
conversation I'm not going to interrupt
her uh I would never interrupt a Hell's
Angel you're so creative you can be like
oh do your friend your best friend Mary
just walked in she's over let's go over
here but you have to understand I was
producing estrogen as well and I was
like maybe I could cook for you guys now
here's the thing maybe I can watch in
the corner and jack up well there's
nothing that takes the Macho out of a
guy like me I'm a macho guy until
there's a guy like that and then all of
a sudden somehow miraculously I lose my
Macho how interesting that is weird all
of a sudden I'm like Oh my voice gets a
little higher my ass perks and you know
I'm just not as aggressive anymore I'm
very aggressive when I'm in a Coffee
Shop full of hipsters or other or other
Comics or other Comics I'm Shadow Boxing
in the corner I'm ready nothing makes me
more sick when I see someone Shadow
Boxing but but I will say that the only
time I actually get out of control angry
is when there's a bully and I will I
I've never seen that H thank God you saw
it I'd be embarrassed you saw it once a
little bit Yeah but uh yeah I mean it's
not look there's no justification for it
it's ridiculous and like your your
question is always the best which is for
what yeah I just don't understand for
what yeah you know like Chrystal Leia
was saying I mean unless you're on the
LAPD like
superhero you know if they're pay if
paying you or something guess chrisa you
could never get Chris Le to fight like
never maybe if you hit his mom it's the
only way yeah because he was in a tank
top in this guy looked and this rough
looking dude just looked at Chris and he
was walking with his tank top and he
looked at Chris's ridiculous tank top
and his hairy chest and he just
went [__] like that made a he didn't
know what to say's wrong with that and
[__] and I said Chris you see that
guy diss you and he goes no and I don't
care yeah I would never fight anyone no
I don't have the well even yeah and then
these two these two dudes go Chris these
two really big muscular looking guys and
they got out of pickup truck in San
Diego and Chris like hey man how are you
and uh and they were talking and talking
and I and we all ended up talking and I
was looking at them and I was like Jes
they look like the big blonde guy and
another guy was just like big and I said
how do you guys know each other we went
to high school with him man we were
really good friends and and uh Chris
goes how you guys are in the military
right and they go yeah yeah and he goes
how's that going he goes ah you know
it's pretty hairy and I go what do you
guys do in the military he goes we're
seals were Navy Seals and they were
clearly seals like you just see them and
everything else and and I was like Chris
they were [__] [__] Navy Seals how
cool is that and Chris goes I don't even
know what that is and I give a [__] like
no interest in anything Macho anything
mail I love that meanwhile I'm you know
you're loving it I'm loving it loving it
loving it yeah yeah they came to the
show Good Guys um anyway what else by
the way um I was uh I was I was gonna I
get such a kick out of they were talking
about [__] um Donald Trump being
Dutch and how being Dutch is uh one of
the reasons he's so blunt because I
don't know if you know that the Dutch
are some of the most um well an that I
mean just a Entertainer yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's a lot more yeah but he's
actually he's actually not his
personality is not that different from
most uh Dutch people which is a really
strange thing I'm trying to find
interesting cor correlation no no no
he's also entertain like he's he's a
Hollywood you know like he was on a huge
show on NBC like he's a he's a celebrity
you know no but they were doing this
really interesting profile about why
he's so blunt like he's so and he
doesn't really take people's feelings
into account like he's always been that
with business just bottom line and stuff
like that so so they always say that the
wor like a lot of people in Europe talk
about the worst people to be around a
lot of times they're nice people but
they're also like really blunt and not
there there's no um what's the word like
you know how there's no filter for sure
and there's no uh sentiment around
things like there's no like when you I
don't know like you would you would
couch something you criticize somebody
say look you're a really good guy man
but maybe you shouldn't be so
overbearing sometimes only because right
they'll be like hey you're a pain in the
ass in a party and you can't come
anymore like it's and the reason they
were doing this thing profile on the
Dutch was that because they're below sea
level and the sea is always there and
they had to build dams they're the best
water engineers in the world like when
the the levy broke in New Orleans they
were all Dutch Engineers they flew them
in because they know how to do that when
you are under the constant threat of
[__] the sea the [__] sea washing
your whole City away you don't really
have time to be nice you got to be like
this works this doesn't [__] you you're
wrong let's go and you and you work
together and they were drawing this
interesting profile about how that's how
that's why he's he's America's Dutch
uncle like that's how he is that's
interesting do they Al do they take in
account that he's born on third base and
he's always had the chips in his Corner
he's just a celebrity that became
president well there's that too cuz he
cuz when you have all the chips in your
corner you're going to talk down to
people he doesn't need some people some
people don't though you he does right he
does and but but also when you don't
need anything from anyone cuz you're
born on third base and you're a
businessman and you have Daddy to fall
back on you're going to interact with
people different yeah that's for sure
for him I mean I mean there's a lot of
guys like who aren't Dutch he's also a
[__] authoritarian I mean's narciss
he's a narcissist man I mean just truly
I would chock it up more being a
narcissist than Dutch yeah there's some
Dutch guys listen going what the [__]
the Dutch are considered very very nice
very tolerant people yeah most of the
Dutch I met
tolerant people but they're very blunt
oh you know what we got uh not a lot of
[__] but guys were send me a ton of
articles on that claim when we're at
dinner that's where I got it from I do
zero fact checking zero fact checking
but when people went man uh rape and
crime is up 1,00% in Sweden German
that's not true well that's why that's
why Jimmy said that's been called into
question yeah
yeah 1600 from your guy at dinner right
who is Swedish and it's not true at all
they sent me so many articles 1600% they
said uh rape has been up but yeah I mean
it's not true at all yeah yeah you have
to be very careful with those statistics
lies damn lies and statistics they're
also saying that a lot of those articles
came out so the American public like see
what happened to them it gives us a
reason like yeah don't let them in
that's right but the actual statistics
are nowhere near that they're just not
and again I mean a lot of these refugees
are women and children man I mean you
put a face on it and it's like I think
most people I think most people if they
saw the faces and they saw what those
people were like they would they would
soften their stance that's all I have to
say yeah it's it's hum all perspective
like you saw it and you saw them at the
airport getting turned away and they're
selling everything they have to come to
America American Dream yeah they're
trying to escape Isis and all the I
would also remind people that syrians
have always been notoriously not
notoriously they've always been
entrepreneurs that is so ingrained in
the culture when you're Lebanese and
Syrian you are an entrepreneur if you
think those people culturally are going
to rely on the government you're out of
your mind the minute the minute they get
to this country they're going to be
looking to to to start their own
business that's so ingrain thean
character I can't tell you weird what's
weird is that uh that shooting Quebec we
went over yesterday like there's like
the president really hasn't done
anything like he no announcement but if
it was an ISIS attack or an a Muslim
extremist you don't think he'd be it'd
be propaganda everywhere for him but
because it's a white Christian yeah
there's nothing yeah not a word like you
really don't see on CN there's no
breaking news on CNN about it yeah but
if it was if he had a hint of the Quran
yeah well Sam Harris to your point Sam
Harris who did this thing with Lawrence
Wright who's [__] one to pull the
surprise for the looming Tower which
just kind of like traces what happened
from the ' 50s to 9/11 and how 911
happened in an exhausted work took him
five years to research he's done Rogan's
podcast twice he's incredible and um he
he basically uh said that most of the
and he did a profile most of the dudes
that did The Killing mostly weren't
islamists they were just [__]
sociopaths a lot of them had been
criminals and then glommed on to the
ideology they killing where like in Iraq
and like Zar for example was a sociopath
he was a criminal he was a sex criminal
he'd been in jail don't live by the
Muslim know the war those Wars attract
some really bad you know sociopaths they
have a license now it's divine license
to Kill yeah so there's a lot of that
too and Sam and Harris that's a debate
that Sam Harris was having but it was
interesting really good Sam people
should listen to that podcast waking up
Sam here is a smart dude yeah you got
some current events chin you got some
good ones today uh you know the main one
I don't know the main one Trump fired
the Attorney General because she
wouldn't defend the immigration ban MH
or the travel ban yeah because you know
this is a pretty big deal it is and
remember that the the president has some
strong Powers one is to Appo to he can
fire almost anybody he wants he just
fire her yeah I'll go through I'll go
through a list of how many people he can
fire actually but that's a that's a good
that's a good I actually have that on my
she sticks to it huh yeah so she she
defended her stance she said that she
didn't feel as though the executive
order was actually lawful and this is
the highest ranking law enforcement
officer in the country she's the number
one she like if anything happens to the
president legally she's the one that has
to take care of it damn powerful Sally
Yates and she's gone now geez yeah fire
yeah I mean I'm sure she's going to fall
on her feet oh yeah for sure everyone's
probably to fall in love with her yeah
she kind of it's going to do more for
her career than working for Trump ever
would probably well she she seems to
have voted her conscience and that takes
a lot of guts but you know the the
president I I have this the president
can appoint and remove the commissioner
of the IRS okay so if you if you know he
he appoints and remove the inspector
generals Who oversee the inter internal
workings of the Cabinet departments and
major agencies he can basically appoint
and remove uh us attorneys almost
anybody he wants the president has broad
powers to do this I think we kind of
knew all that though not really because
executive power is something real and
and and you know the scary thing is when
you cross this guy he's the president he
can he but more than anybody else this
guy takes these personal vendettas very
seriously the president I think that's
why people are scared you know like
people always go ah well there's going
to be a lot of you know they don't have
as much control as you think he's still
the president they got a lot of control
yeah a lot I mean this lady even with
this immigration thing man when he when
he has executive power like that the
courts historically don't really
challenge the president's you know
Authority man damn what a powerful lady
yeah eight good for her and her PJ's
right now watching the news now got
fired not easy what else she got she had
to make a stand she did the airport
shooter in
Florida he had his day in court and he's
pleading not guilty to all 22 counts is
he representing himself I love that he
has a lawyer actually he does present
themselves yeah yeah I know but I mean
obviously there's video camera footage
you see him pull the gun shooting
obviously I'm wondering why would
someone why would someone do that if
they're obviously on camera killing
people and pleading not guilty he might
plead not guilty to Insanity right it
depends on the charges yeah I think you
would do it Insanity Not Guilty by
Insanity which I guess he was kind of
insane man definitely insane but courts
are also not very from what I've read
They're not that uh sympathetic to an
insanity play cuz the it hinges on
whether or not at the moment you knew
whether you were right or wrong like you
whether you knew what you were doing was
quote unquote right or wrong and I kind
of like that they're not that lenient
with Insanity [__] I just think you're a
young man this guy deserves to be put
down like a [__] dog I see if you're
a young man and you're hearing voices
and you have a history like they said of
of mental illness and your family's been
talking about it and then you open fire
is is what I think he has to be put away
but does he get put away in a mental
hospital or in a jail do you want to
punish somebody who's hearing voices and
might be crazy or do you want to just
put him in a [__] hospital and keep
them away from society I don't feel
vindictive you put him in a hospital and
then do what being then give them treat
well for the criminally insane they but
I know but then you give him treatment I
don't know I don't know how that works
higher tax payers money I don't know how
it works after the guy took six lives
it's like I just think after you kill
then you just go to jail no matter what
that's kind of how yeah but if you're
crazy yeah if you're mentally ill CU it
an illness yeah it's a tough thing cuz
that you know to send him away to a
mental institution it cost taxpayers
more money he took six lives then you re
rehabilitate him for to put them back
out Society no that privilege is gone
yeah I don't think you I don't think you
rehabilitate him I think I'm just saying
that I would rather see somebody who
hearing voices and who might truly be
crazy I'd rather see them uh in some
place away from society but not being
raped or beaten up because he's he's
crazy I'd rather see him just kind of
put away somewhere maybe if there was
like other crazies yeah mentally ill gel
that's why we have criminal that's why
we have well they say the the number one
issue in LA County Jail which is
overpopulated is mental illness but
they're not they can't address it like
they're not getting the proper treatment
I saw it I mean it's a vicious Cy
because he took six lives I really don't
give a [__] if the homies run a train on
them have to though as a society in
other words like at the society yeah if
if I guarantee if that was your sister
your brother-in-law when you're that's
you would be like that's why it's called
objective law and that's objective right
so that's why I don't make laws so so in
other words like when I went to uh Miami
dat County jail and I spent a week there
I went into the area where and they they
we do house our our mentally ill um
people we don't put them in hospitals
for the most part and but we do have
hospitals for the criminally insane we
do um but you know when I went there and
I saw like this one dude they all all I
said had done something to children and
I don't have any sympathy for that but
dude he was wearing a nylon vest and he
was standing there and he was clutching
his hands and he was [__] talking in
tongues and did he what' he do he raped
tell me what he did but he right we
don't need that guy on this Earth well
so you got to get rid of him so here's
my question termin yeah so so you either
shoot him in the head like a sick dog
correct or you you put him you know in a
but he was in an aquarium in a jail in
an aquarium I'm talking about a glass
aquarium and they have somebody sit and
watch you you sit a guard sits in a
little plastic chair and watches you all
day as you sleep on a steel it's a steel
cot it's 100% stainless steel and
nothing else is there that's more than I
would give and you're in a nylon thing
and you're sleeping there this guy was
so clearly out of his mind that do you
re rehabilitate him so he nobody's
talking about real I know but but so
he's what I'm saying so what would you
so you give him whatever drugs you want
so he's not as crazy I would you put him
in general population with the prisoners
no no no what I would do is I would with
people who are that crazy regardless of
what they did um you know I would say
that person's not of his right mind okay
so I would put him in a hospital for the
criminally insane which would mean I I
think I would put him under the the
supervision and care of a doctor so it's
not punitive it's punitive enough but at
least if somebody's that crazy they need
they need to be monitored by medical
professionals whether it's with drugs or
whatever I don't get any I don't get any
satisfaction about putting somebody's
truly out of their mind in gen pop in
fact I think it's bad for the other
prisoners too uh and and by the way by
the way what we do with those people is
we put them in a glass aquarium for 23
hours a day they go even more crazy I
know and I don't want to live in a
society like that I I just don't I I
don't I know we all want punishment and
of course I suffer from that too I
always want you you touch a child I get
let me get in the room with you with a
[__] bat you know I know but
there are people that are that are there
some people that just lost causes though
when a guy who hurt a child or committed
murder and he's so out of his [__]
mind okay then we're going to appoint
this doctor to make sure that this guy
is okay and that is the rest of his life
he lives out okay that's insane well
usually usually they they they live in a
quiet environment where they can you
know where they're just they're just
taken care of as a crazy person I know
that's that's what I that's what I would
say you should do with those that's they
they add nothing to society it's
taxpayers money well and then how many
do you have so do you have a and how
much how many mental insane patients are
there have committed horrible crimes I
know but but also that'd be like saying
it is taxpayer money but so is somebody
on a feeding tube and so is somebody
who's severely [__] and I don't
think we live want to live in a society
that gets rid of those people who are C
difference is the sever so the severely
mentally handicapped and the didn't kill
somebody didn't hurt anybody what what
I'm saying is that we do know that there
are you can have lesions in your brain
or a kind of brain where you lose your
mind for whatever reason and it caused
you to do things that you would never do
in a right your right mind including
murder I know you have to be held
accountable but the insanity defense
which we have the insanity defense would
be that you can't hold that person
accountable because they were not in
their right mind their mind stopped
working we know that that's a a real
phenomenon now the debate hinges on
whether or not he was a his right mind
right so he let's take this let's take
this gentleman who was uh in the Army
Reserve right he's in uh Alaska right
Anchorage I don't know either way he's
in he goes in has the conscious mind to
enter in the Army Reserves pass all that
go to school pass all that right he he
went to Iraq I know he was like a Iraq
veteran went over there Iraq came back
uh goes into the police station or FBI
tells him I'm hearing voices so he has
the conscious mind to do that says I'm
in voices books his PL it to fly home
tell a lot has the conscious mind to
pack his carry-on gun in his checked in
baggage with the bullets comes up with
the master plan cuz he said that the
government was controlling his yeah sure
so comes up with the master plan that
when he gets off he goes in the bathroom
to load it walks out again the crazy
people don't really think like this come
out and then unloads on six people yeah
they do so crazy people do that so crazy
people if they think somebody's
controlling their mind and that people
are not people they might be aliens they
can be very cool and I mean the the
scary thing about insanity is that
you're totally sane when you're planning
it yeah because you're you're killing
you're not killing people you're killing
Federal robots or whoever they might
aliens or whoever it is so he never
thought that but he never thought that
was an noral Reserve High School any of
that oh yeah but we don't know but
people can go crazy you know people I
mean for example schizophrenia hits
young men in their 20s and early 30s
more than it does any other group
schizophrenia is something I don't think
you give him a pass man and I don't
think and I know I might get shipped for
this I have zero tolerance for it we do
not need that guy on this Earth so you
would well I mean that's that's an
argument for the death penalty which you
know 100% he should get death penalty I
I mean if it was just some guy okay not
just some guy but someone killed someone
but there wasn't footage there wasn't
you know hardcore footage yeah then it's
tougher cuz you know he has to have his
day in court cuz it's possibly not him
in this case he killed people I see his
face clear as day on the on the video
camera he just I feel like regardless if
he was in if he was sane or not insane
he killed people we know it's him that
did it he should go some people don't
care yeah I mean I get the argument like
whether he was crazy or not we don't
know because we don't know the inner
markings of a man we don't have the
instruments and he also had time to
think of this whole thing same with this
is going to come out in court this is
exactly what the his defense is going to
argue pru defense the prosecution to eat
this [__] up yeah I mean and and usually
these guys do get something like the
death like the the the kid who did the
the shootings uh that killed all the
African-Americans at the church it was
like oh I'm clinically insane you see
what happened to him and he was like uh
I I
uh he did on purpose and he said like
yeah after before he was going to say he
was insane then homeboy uh at the Aurora
uh theater shootings same thing tried
playing Insanity well he thought he was
the Joker didn't he I mean he got caught
I think those guys are crazy I really
think they definitely I mean I think
when you open up like that you are
insane it's like the guy that killed
Valerie the I mean shot her in the head
and killed that nine-year-old girl I
mean terrible but he was insane he
shaved his eyebrows he was like this and
he's he's [__] criminally insane I
don't get any satisfaction either yes
either shoot him you get satisfaction of
putting him in a mental I don't get any
satisfaction out of putting him in a
prison and punishing a crazy person that
guy was so clearly crazy that for me
either will you do one of two things
shoot him like a sick dog cuz he's never
going to get better we know we're never
letting him out because we don't know
when he's going to have his next episode
we all know that he's not coming out my
same feeling with when you molest
children you rape children you're never
getting out of jail there's no 18year
sentence [__] I you have an
Impulse you can't control for me you
either go to jail forever or we should
just kill you you can make your choice
okay uh because you're never coming out
and it's the same thing with a guy like
this so we know he's criminally insane
even if he gets better with a hospital I
don't trust that [__] CU I don't know
when he's going to get better again
so do you as a society Warehouse him in
a hospital or do you put him down like a
sick dog that's the only those that's
the question and you know what I'm kind
of sympathetic to both points of view I
mean I hate to say it I wish I was more
on your way I just have zero tolerance
what I think they don't help the society
they only hurt society and we got a lot
of [__] to do and I would shoot them
just like you were saying if it was
someone that you knew that you cared
about you loved that he did it to you
there would be no I don't think there
would be any that's not how you make
laws of that's
you the point of our country is it's a
rule it's rule of law and law stands
objective right it stands as regardless
of the circumstances are taken into
account but you let leave that to a
judge I think a heinous crime like that
it's just Zero Tolerance on camera it's
him
guaranteed yeah what else you got chin
it's an intering conversation it's a
real problem yeah cuz and how and these
days how many people are are claiming or
pleading Insanity more so than ever they
know for a fact that they can get well
that's a way out right that's a
loophole every oh Insanity mental health
everyone mental health weird we didn't
have these problems all the like 30 40
years ago I know but it's the times and
now we have better research so it's a
lot more mental health is it yeah is it
weird cuz man I swear like when I was a
kid there wasn't so much add and now
everyone has ADD or the kids just have a
lot of energy and you're giving them
sugar up the yingyang m is there more
money in giving them drugs cuz the
pharmaceutical companies are diagnos
when I was a kid there was only I don't
know five vaccination shots they're 60
now yeah I'm I'm sorry I'm having a hard
time oh it's
research gotcha or is it money gotcha
there more incentive in is there more
money or is by keeping these guys alive
in the taxpayers money it's it's giving
the prisons more money or it's you know
someone's benefiting from this very I
have a hard time dealing with it man oh
yeah that kid has ad
uh man he he just you know he's
sensitive to this or he doesn't play
well with others let me ask you this
here bullying weird cuz kids were
bullied when I was a kid they grew up
just fine they figured that [__] out I
agree with you I agree with you but
here's a here's a you're starting to
sound like an old guy here but you're
right now here's here's my question
here's a question I'll pose for you so
and as they learn more about the brain
you know and they find that serial
killers have different brains like they
do um sometimes they can have an underd
amydala you know that part of the brain
that registers emotion serotonin
dopamine all that whatever it is or they
have something with their brain I know
you're going with this go ahead yeah so
now I'm able to do I'm able to prove
this [__] is yeah and they they
have a faulty brain their computer
broken now if they can detect that you
don't think they have the technology to
help that so here's my question to add
to the brain so they're not let me make
it worse for you cuz there's going to be
Pros there's going to be advancements
that are going to be able to help that
okay so first of all so if I prove that
has a faulty Brain before I'm going to
give I'm going to give you two scenarios
got a faulty brain sir I'm showing you
on on the graph he's serial killer
probably now now we know he serial kill
or he is a serial killer and we can
prove that he has he has brain damage
does he fall under the the the the
Americans with Disabilities Act first of
all he's got a disability he's got a
disability just like somebody has no
legs but it's a different thing it's a
brain thing now what does that say about
punishing him now hold on hold on since
he's actually got a faulty brain he
should probably be put in a mental
institution or something not jail CU
it's not his fault yeah or how about
this um uh sir we uh we see his killed
16 people very heinously uh he's got a
[__] up brain but we have the
technology to make his brain better and
make him a productive citizen so uh do
you put him in jail or do you fix his
brain and put him back out there because
he's a new person might just have to put
him down because that's a different
person right I know but you know what I
mean if you have the if you have the
we're going to get there you have the
technology to fix a bad person's brain
so that they didn't get sexually excited
or whatever by killing people whatever
it was and they suddenly became a
completely different person what do you
do here's one for you B what happens if
we find out that they think oh it's a
chemical imbalance it's a mental
insanity and we have all this stuff and
when you're born you get a shot where
let's make sure he's not
crazy you're I think you're being
unrealistic if you don't think there's
still going to be bad seeds no matter
what I think there's just some people
and it drives me nuts when people go
it's a it's a mental issue like oh how
he killed his mother wore her face and
then shot three more and then rape kids
yeah okay yeah okay or he's just a
terrible person or or he's [__]
there's good and bad there's there's
always going to be good and bad there
are some people who are mentally insane
but also we all have good and bad in us
like the whole point of Free Will and
choices the fact that I have a bad side
I have a good side and every day I fight
to be better than I am bad but there
might be a time when you're in traffic
someone cut you off and you know you go
you're having a bad day God [__] kill
that guy there's a part of me I goes
you're not going to do [__] I get the
emotion then there's some people
actually like I'm having such a bad day
and I'm emotional right now I'm going to
try and kill this guy there go there you
go you got to you got to be held
accountable for your lack of self
control he's not insane he's just
doesn't have his emotions under control
acted on uh you know look character
character is defined to self-control
when you when you break down when you
don't have char when you don't have
self-control you bang that girl you're
not supposed to you punch that guy in
the face cuz he [__] you took
something you really wanted but you
couldn't afford but it didn't belong to
you we got a thousand examples of that
it's why you have laws it's why you have
a trial it's why you have a judge it's
why you do time it's why you get
convicted or you don't get people kill
for jealousy maybe that guy has
something you you've always wanted you
failed at everything in your life that
guy's driving the Ferrari he has the hot
chick has the kids in the back and
you're this guy just never worked out
for whatever reason you you made
horrible choices and then something
happens to that guy now jealousy you
kill that guy well how about how about I
just think we we chalk up everything to
mentally insanes too way too much mental
illness uh all all I was talking with my
[__] um I don't give my neighbor
talking about our kid and we we can't
have we can't have anything with gluten
or sugar in the house and because I had
these Stevia uh Cokes you know St if
you're going to drink Coke that's
probably what you want to drink I forget
what theia exia I'm like here you can
have we cannot have get those out don't
let him see those I'm like why we he
can't be around those can't even touch
him all right he and he has so much
energy he might have ADD he's three like
he doesn't have ADD yeah they're buying
in all're oh and then we we only allow
100% organic clothing on him and we
can't have any pesticides and there's no
we don't turn on the AC I'm like your
kid's so [__] already it's not even
funny God also you can't play with my
kid you you guys can't I can't have you
even look in my direction yeah you guys
are bat [__] crazy yeah you're breeding
a doesn't have and you have you oh my
God you see this
kid oh my God oh my God it makes me want
to move out understand and move to the
[__] got a lot of that [__] in
California yeah you just do I'm sorry
you get a lot of especially where you
are especially that area ad and they
want to give medication I'm like he's
three of course he has energy have you
ever thought to take him to a park maybe
let at the beach right there # live on
the beach you might you ever think about
right there maybe a [__] bike ride
that's what sports are for that's what
rough crazy man it's I just look at I'm
like that you're the problem you're the
[__] problem of course of course and
you're 100% right about that man how old
are those parents like are they young
old enough to know better uh yeah
mid-30s mid-30s 40s on the West Side you
see a lot of it a lot of it's also when
you start reading too much like you know
we I get in F with my wife about this
she'll read the new psychology and you
know you should never punish a child
ever because is punishing a child is
suppresses suppresses their spirit I
don't tell that I don't have to talk to
anybody I look at how shit's been done
forever in cultures that been around
forever and not not all them a lot of
them are doing just fine and I also know
that that people can be kids can be
little [__] and they will [__]
take a mile if you don't go hey one more
time one more time and you get nothing I
mean my dad never hit me in the face we
spank my ass if I messed up then I was
like you know what I shouldn't be doing
that he's right like I'm not going to
again but when people go no no no you
get on their level you talk to them my
eye to eye and let them know you're
unhappy when they do that I'm like what
the [__] are you talking about he's one
he has no idea what I'm referring to
that does not what are you talking about
try five years old try five years old
when they grw up with that and I don't I
don't I say to my son all the time I go
let me exp I swear to God I talked this
way I go the other day I go let me
explain something to you I'm not your
mother and this is not a democracy this
is a dictatorship and what I say goes
that's how it is sometimes my friend
that's just the way we do things you're
not going to eat that candy right now
and that's the way it is and you can
scream and cry but that's it there's
certain things you got to be like shut
the [__] not you know but that this is
the law of the land kids need boundaries
I don't give a [__] what anybody says I
think yeah there my mother used to hit
me with a riding crop along the legs I
remember running from her she'd take out
her [__] riding crop cuz I and by the
waying I haven't been scarred by it I
deserved it I was a little [__] I
remember being a shitthead I bet you're
a nightmare oh my dad was the wall my
mother would just have to go Mike and my
father would go and I go I'm good I'm
good terrified my dad I don't you have
to have just a respect there has to be a
happy medium like uh last night my son
was doing D he oh he's opening the
cabinets he keeps open like playing with
the stuff old playing with the stuff and
my girl's like tiger no you know and she
she's super disciplined and she'll hit
him and then he kept doing it and she
spanked his butt and he turned around
had the saddest face and then he looks
at me goes Dad D and I'm like yeah
that's right let's get out of
here even at that age he knows where to
go I'm not yeah I'm not the discipline
like I'm not the when it comes to sports
or like School albe discipline but when
it comes to that stuff dud when he
looked at me was like Dad I'm like yeah
your mom's [__] up let's get out of
here you outside and went for a little
walkie walk I was like I know your
mother's an [__] I don't know what
we're going to
do I wanted to love me yes D dude my son
does d game over said D I need a fry
we'll figure it out okay yeah let that
never stops when I'm when I scold her my
daughter eight8 years old I want my mom
when my mom my wife scolds my daughter
she's like I want Daddy I can hear it
I'm like you're I love it oh yeah yeah
well what else you got chin on a light
well not a lighter note but oh dude I I
can't watch my kid get shots when I
watch my kid get a shot I had to leave
the I can't watch him cry it's to I
can't take it my wife's like you're such
a [__] get out of here I never go to
the doctor anymore I can't take it gone
cuz I hate the doctor yeah all right so
Selene haga do you know that girl that
lost a match because she choked out her
opponent and the bell rang afterwards Y
and then she ended up losing yeah
exactly so she went to the Missouri
commission that's where the fight was
held at and they didn't they said nope
it's whatever ruling stands because the
r the referee was the one in charge so
they wrot her so she has this loss on a
record now way too much power for the
referee did you guys hear about this
fight I'm sure you guys heard about it
probably talked about it so she Asian
girl's name is hagga the other one is I
forgot her Montenegro was her opponent
Montenegro had her in an armar in the
first round and then after the bell rang
hagga tapped right that's how the first
round went but since it was after the
Bell it's fine right that makes sense
that does make sense but this is the
last round where the third round or
fifth round I'm not sure she choked her
and then the bell rang and she let her
go the girl was passed out cuz the but
this is the issue she was unconscious
before the bell rang and then the Bell
rangs and the ref jumps in but she's out
it's not a tough one the ref didn't has
no idea what the [__] is going on
because anyone knows when you're in a
deep choke like that it doesn't take a
lot of time before they're out so she's
out but the ref doesn't make a quick
enough decision to stop the fight CU her
body didn't go limp or something no
she's limp but he he didn't realize it
so how can you give the ref that much
power and on top of that she she wanted
the appeal but the Missouri office of
Athletics they they basically wrote her
a regular kind of you know that that we
look at the rules yeah they they don't
they didn't really look at it they just
said nope it's in the referee's hands
and the referee you know say I don't
give a [__] she's not famous enough to
make waves and so check this out I
looked at her record and she was talking
about how she works her butt off to to
be in this position and this win would
have been huge for her right so look at
her record she was one in 11 coming up
she lost four in a row then won one God
BL her soul for sticking with it seven
in a row might not be for you girl and
then she started getting on this awesome
streak right yeah and that last fight
would have been huge for her she's
trying to she's fighting to get her
record even right now and then she wants
to make it to the UFC well so it's like
this loss is humongous on her record
yeah that really screws her over
although the the new matchmakers will
take that into account but her record is
so salty crazy right but she's a fighter
look at this no she she a fighter some
would say a loser
yeah might take Los although she has way
more wins now right so if you look at
her she only has three losses so she
started out losing a lot and and she
started out and she ended winning lot
never gave up just kept going for that's
that's somebody yeah she and then her
only two losses are one obviously I'm
not going to count that last one she won
that fight when she choked that girl out
but she lost a split decision she lost a
unanimous decision not bad so those are
close and that girl's really really good
toar yeah she's killing it man she's
doing well hopefully the guys in the UFC
doing the matchmaking letter her and
especially now she has all this
controversy they should they should help
her
out and she's an Invicta I don't even
know doesn't
matter what's the tougher weight
division in women's all tough no but no
easy weight class 115 and 135 are I mean
they're
she they're all tough but she's going to
be taking she says she's looking into
taking it to actual court now God 10 and
14 it's going to be tough to sell that
to the UFC I could be honest with you
that is real even with her because that
pops up on the thing and they're like
Jesus Christ man she's also 32 it's time
to get going H 32 hug hug H she's 32 10
and 14 Huga it's going to be a tough
sell Hugga Hugga it's cool name I hope
she makes it though we're rooting for
you haa yep what else you got man not
poor girl choke the girl out unconscious
and the stupid ref didn't identify it
early enough so she
loses even if I was a judge even as a
judge you can't judge the whole fight
like well she got choked down I'm gonna
give it to her even you know yeah yeah
human about it be human about even a ref
I'm like well she won I don't give a
[__] what happen W two and even in the
third round she choked onc conscious I
mean we'll vote on it but we got to give
to this girl I get a kick out of dooho
Choy I like that name dooho dooho do do
Ho Choy Yoo dooho huh from Korean names
right now do ho Doo Choy that makes
sense doo doo would have been he's a
monster would have been funnier though
Doo what else you have brother um Derek
fiser he got robbed and they took all
five of his NBA rings that going to be
tough to replace oh it's tough to
replace won't the NBA kind of replace
him sure won't oh don't work like that
come on those super expensive too right
I mean you're obviously going to have to
wheel and deal them on the black Market
because you can't just put them up on
eBay it's easy to yeah they'll they have
cameras in every freaking pawn
shop also well the pawn shot wouldn't be
the black market either there's a market
where you go to like the dark web yeah
the guy who is smart enough to break
into an NBA player's house and steal his
ring and go for the jewelry not going to
go sounds like an inside job not going
to go in your local Easy Pond be like
who wants them sounds like an inside job
here's a question did we ever find out
what happened with Kim Kardashian
getting tied up and inside job yeah
inside job it was an inside job yeah her
head of in in uh France I think got
arrested and the chauffeur that was
showing around too inside job we were
right on that remember I called that I
mean it's not rocket science it's pretty
obvious job this I don't know because
Kevin Hart's house got broken into too
it's going around in Hollywood yeah and
Caesar Milan the dog was they steal his
dogs I don't know what they that' be
classic they steal like his main best
trained dog it's so easy to break into a
house house but it has to be inside
right cuz everyone these are really
fortressed houses and they know exactly
where to go really high Lev burglars or
that well when you have a house so many
people are working on your house all the
time roof you know well guy's got a
chicken with moisture in the wall
whatever hey scroll down to what to say
about it they don't know your
[__] $300,000 worth of valuable jewelry
wow TP he left the home at 7:30 a.m. so
they did in the morning because they
knew he was gone M went through a side
door yeah
it's someone who yeah Brian's right who
worked on the house something like that
who knows his routine you see them all
there's 15 guys that come to your house
work on everything so how you there's
always one bad guy sucks
man always one bad guy five rings yeah
the money I'm sure he can he can handle
that but the Rings are the the ones that
are the real bummer I'm sure he stole
more than $300 worth of valuable didn't
he have Arm System that's the question
well if you're right if someone's
working on the house they have to turn
it off for the people working through it
right yep
you that's a bummer yeah I don't like it
makes me want to live in I'm gonna have
to hire a bunch of security guards dude
well Kevin remember Kevin Hart lived in
calabas is in a secure area they broke
into that [__] house there's been
multiple guys yeah that's crazy that's
Kevin Hart money he screws McDuck of
Comedy yeah how the hell they break into
his house that again for sure ins up no
no no no there's been multiple like
famous people at the house that broke in
some high LEL profession you know what
that's yeah you're never going to stop
professionals that's their career those
dudes who are just you know like tal
like heat like heat yeah like those
dudes what else do you got J that
[__] sucks though this one was just
interesting to read so Anderson Silva
says he's going to take on Hollywood and
he actually said that he wrote something
for Netflix and then they bought the
idea does that happen ever uh yes but
when he says he wrote it what that means
is there's an idea and then they'll get
some writers and someone wrote it yeah
he has an idea
it's hard to write you know when you
when you're a great fighter so he still
wants to apart from his dream of doing
the Spock fight against Roy Jones I've
always had the dream of being an action
movie
star everybody wants to be an
actor he wasn't some um B movie yeah
he's been in some movies MMA
movies um but I was surprised when they
said that when he said that he wrote the
show and it got bought got bought by
Netflix
huh well I don't know what to say about
that I don't know how the Brazilian
Market is I mean the us it's going to be
tough to cross over but Aston Sil is
pretty big you know but I I don't know
yeah I don't know interesting to see
when he actually does do an action film
and he sees what acting's really
about how yeah but there's been some
crossover guys that like a lot of guys
who've done it like him in an action
movie is in a far stretch if he said I
want to be the next Daniel de Lewis then
then I think it's out of his grasp for
him to be in some
Expendable seven fast infurious seven
any of that stuff that's easy wants a
gun shoot it that's easy day bisbing is
in the in the new one I'm not saying
it's easy but it's not out of the realm
for him to do it sure I don't think you
know Arnold Schwarzenegger is not
exactly the most gifted actor of all
time highest paid you know his range
isn't great right but I don't think
that's a good point yeah but I'm still
attracted to watching his movies but
he's never been super super he's the
same guy in every movie except for twins
I think he was good in twins but it's on
sweger you know the highest py you know
we're going to watch Arnold yeah but
when and and I get it even now but when
actors here here he goes acting it's
like yes he didn't go to juliard and
he's not he's not gonna be crying on
film well if you think about if you
think about like arold Schwarzenegger he
was working with James Cameron and the
Terminator which was an incredible movie
an incredibly futuristic movie and James
Cameron some he worked with Incredible
directors and and Visionary writers and
uh he was playing a robot so they they
he came up very yeah come with me if you
want to live you know I'll be back and
all that Commando like he do you know
he's playing himself like he's not
playing he didn't have he's never played
a movie where as a American accent like
it's him as the Austrian like same ACC
every single movie Yes Morgan Freeman
like it's [__] Morgan Freeman no
range it's Morgan Freeman yeah like you
don't you book you can call Morgan red
all you want I see Morgan Freeman on the
screen oh no I think Morgan Freeman's
one of the great actors I think he's
great yeah amazing but yeah I mean as
soon as you recognize him it's not like
Morgan Freeman's playing some gangster
on [__] you know well Morgan Freeman
has the ability yet I think he kind of
transcends his personality is powerful
enough and his acting is good enough
that you buy him as that guy as Morgan
Freeman in almost everything everything
Samuel Jackson same Jack Nicholson was
sort of the same way too I mean that
that you know so there are there are
actors that become a character like
Daniel D Lewis Christian Bale and then
there are actors like Jean Hackman and
you know Morgan Freeman and highly
highly crafted and skilled but they they
have such you believe everything they do
that it's okay they have such they have
such weight as themselves that you you
don't mind Morgan fan can play a really
kind person I buy it and then he can
play a killer and speak in the same
voice and somehow you buy it somehow
you're like you know but he's never
really played the killer he's played
like the nice you know God and Bruce all
might then he's played the the creepy
not creepy but like the weird
introverted detective in seven but
either way when he was younger when he
was younger he played in fact he got his
break because he had to play a pimp and
he tells the story and uh instead of
like threatening the girl the casting
director he walked up to her he's a big
man he walked up to her and he just
moved her hair out of her eyes as he
said the line he didn't Hur her he just
moved her hair gently out of her eyes
and the [__] producer looked at him
and said you've you've done this before
and he said excuse me he said in real
life you've done that before and he said
maybe I have maybe I haven't or
something like that yeah I'm and they
gave the part you yeah I bet he knew
Beast see what makes Morgan Freeman
great is he knows he understands human
behavior on a deep level I great actors
understand that uh but back derson Sil
yeah I don't listen I he's not trying to
be Morgan Freeman or anything like that
for Anderson Silva to star in some
action movie that we've seen Ronda
Rousey do Conor McGregor's had offers
you know you look at Hollywood right now
it's not a I mean it's not surprising
yeah indeed with a good director I don't
I mean I I'm not even a good
director it's not it's not like he the
movie the movie what you have to do with
Anderson you have to have you have to
have a good movie around a guy like that
and you have to cast him in a limited
role just like with Terminator and
Arnold Schwarzenegger you have to see I
don't think he's trying to be see I see
I think people that I don't think he's
trying to be that I think he would be in
something like the Expendable 7 where
there's a entire cast I mean people
around him that got huge support system
where he can play Terminator it was just
Arnold Schwarz there wasn't like a whole
Squad but you look at the new action
movies it's a there's like a lot to take
on yeah but the acting was left in
Terminator in movies like that to Linda
Hamilton to you know uh you know what I
mean the urgency and the emotion was
left to him he was a robot there was no
emotion he was a cyborg and he was just
moving forward like a missile all he had
to play was a guy holding a gun shooting
people you know and again that that's
what I mean is you you have to cast
Silva could be I don't know maybe he's
brilliant but for the most part you want
to keep him voice is high you want to
keep him in very he has that very high
voice yeah you want to keep him I would
have him I'll be back I would cast him
as an assassin I'm not scared of that I
would cast him as a smiling High voed
assassin too much sir cast as a guy who
[__] you know he's the bad guy who
can fight his ass off and barely says
anything he's very mysterious he barely
talks probably has a stupid hat on in a
suit the whole time and he's the last
guy you get through before you get to
the boss that's it but make him smile
make him smile with with like one gold
tooth and just kind of be and have him
say something like welcome you know and
welcome my name is peace bring it I come
in peace yeah you could but I mean he's
got that heavy accent it's got to be a
it's got to be a movie in Portuguese I'd
imagine in I I don't know I have no idea
that's the first I've heard of
it interesting good for him though CH
son sold the show to Netflix though yeah
that's as a
writer as a
writer I love when they say I mean since
you guys know the game like how that
works the inner workings of
that what that means when you say I sold
a show it's my favorite thing everybody
loves to say that in Hollywood and what
that really means is that you went and
you pitched a concept and then they will
pay you to write the script that's
typically what it means to sell a show
so they'll give you a so they'll give
you a writer's fee and then you you
present them with the pilot and then
they give you notes on that then you
come back then they give you more notes
and then finally they approve the script
if they Greenlight the script then you
get another fee then you go into
production and that production means you
shoot a pilot which you test but with
Netflix they might pick up six see how
it does etc etc but usually you'll shoot
a pilot and then they'll look at that
and say all right we like this get rid
of this actor let's change this and
either way cool [__] man as a world
champion one the best fighters of all
time to sell a show to Netflix and then
take Hollywood auditions it's pretty
cool and when you sell a script what
they'll do typically is the production
company will buy the script but that
just means here's a here's a fee here's
a fee well here's a fee we'll give you
uh 50 grand for to to hold the script
and give us a year and if we can get
this script into production we can get
actors attached to it and stuff into a
production then you get the full fee
then then you'll get your 100,000 $200
$400,000 so it but it has to go into
production otherwise you get it back
after a year or whatever the contract
says so there a lot of
steps cool stuff though from that guy
the great for my money best fighter of
all time UFC what else you got Jen
tarish PE so hard after this next is
that it uh there's one more it's just
Daniel white went on record saying that
he believes Ronda Rousey is she's done
fighting on that in other news one yeah
he he said he talked to her on Monday
and he truly believes that it's it's
done good Fair smart decision riding off
to the
sunset he says she's got a lot of money
she's never going to need money again
first of all unless she spend money like
crazy unless you spend money like Floyd
Mayweather you know how much money that
that guy has more money than Dana so uh
you're not going to going to need money
again when you have the kind of money
that Rhonda has she's not a big spanner
she's got a cute place down in Venice
California waited to say where she
lives CH the world she's been part of
the biggest fights in
history I hope those records can be
broken I don't know if they are but I
hope they
can that's fair I mean I think we kind
of knew she was done though
yeah h
there you go what what's the what's the
highlighted part say at the top oh
that's when he was just saying that when
he talked to her he did he said he
doesn't want to put it out there but
he's pretty sure she's done after that
conversation that he had with her on the
phone on Monday I mean did he call to
see if she would fight
again Hey listen UFC 209s really lack
Lester is there any way we could take
just one more run at Amanda Nunes what
you how do you feeling about
that
good for her though that I mean it's
obviously a tough thing no matter if she
went out on top or you know off to
devastating losses it's tough decision
to
make but least at least she's one of the
the ones that has money in the bank and
she's kind of set she doesn't need the
UFC you know she she doesn't need
anything she doesn't need movies which I
think she'll probably still do some but
she doesn't need Hollywood she doesn't
need the UFC she needs nothing she's
financially set so it's pretty cool
that's a good story I know we look at
negative but it's actually a good story
if you think about it hopefully you know
hopefully there's no so young to me CT
or head trauma or anything like that
so it's actually a positive story if if
you look at it yep I mean we're thinking
our last two fights was actually pretty
positive story MH yeah she doesn't need
the money I didn't really think about
that he's right not a big spender not
doesn't doesn't like lavish things
doesn't she's doing it
right boom b boom is that it that's it
PE so hard let's go
hey oh I need to give a shout out to
homeboy who did the uh we're getting a
lot of questions on who did the the big
ass uh flag behind us the wood
thing you guys if you're looking for
this um it's
lgcy so go his website's ww.
lgcy decore.com so he does any custom
pieces we had this custom Cal flag done
and then he does American flags he does
it all so hit him up it's uh his
Instagram's lgcy deor that's who did
this bad boy and I love it it looks so
much better in person too when you're
right next to isn't it cool yeah yeah
you got your droing knowledge B
yeah I do it's a weird one but it's
interesting if it's about Trump being
Dutch and that's why is he is I'm going
to punch you in the dick
nope nope it's it's so
interesting uh here's my dropping
knowledge and it's interesting because
we are um you know I always think it's
important to put yourself in position of
your enemy like how would I behave under
those circumstances maybe it'll teach
you to understand your enemy a little
better which I think is important when
fighting your enemy and I think men like
the most important thing they say for
men is to feel significant like we want
to feel important you know you ever
notice that like like that's like what
what what is fight if you diss a fighter
if you diss his honor like I've noticed
that with like soldiers honor is so
important feeling significant and stuff
respect yeah and um maybe maybe that's
some of what goes on in the world you
know when when men no longer feel
significant there are a lot of
psychologists that talk about how when
they live under oppressive regimes and
there's nowhere to express themselves
like in the Middle East which are
basically tyrannies the only place to
express yourself is in the MOs and so
they start [__] each other I'm glad
you said the bedroom I was going to say
the mosque but not the bedroom because
they're all kind that yeah well that's
what that's why I paus they suppress
themselves and then they just start
sucking dick well no I've seen it happen
over and over okay I have not seen a lot
of guys do that history okay I haven't
seen that either sir but if you would
let me the Mongols okay no the Mongols
there wasn't a lot of I I don't I didn't
read there was a lot of homosexuality in
the Mong Mongols happened in Jerusalem
okay I don't know about that Brandon the
point is this I'm going to have to ask
you to keep your comments to yourself
sir just feel and you know but it's it's
it's weird how that that's what human
beings do and and so in in the Middle
East which are again tyes the the mosque
is the only place where you can kind of
express yourself and vent your anger and
join a group like the Muslim Brotherhood
and stuff like that so you know a lot of
it's these tyrannies but I was reading
about sort of this uh rise of this
Federal lands you know this thing that
Rogan's been posting about Federal lands
yeah being being up for sale and um you
know there are grazing rights you know
there are always grazing rights for you
have a right to graze your cattle
certain way but this is a very
contentious issue where you can sell off
land and hunters and outdoorsmen are
like I want that land for use if you
sell that [__] I don't know all the
details um but I do know that um and I I
listen to some really interesting stats
here in the where do you think the
highest suicide rate is like where's the
highest suicide rate in this country
Seattle and their dentists in the
that's not bad Seattle where would you
guys say you saying they're dentists
dentists have the highest suicide rate
wow like job
occup yeah occupation well the American
West you didn't know that no I didn't
staring that [__] teeth all day the
they've been school forever think about
it yeah especially if you get some
Chompers like like the guy who's going
to do C's work on your bottom teeth he
looks at and goes oh my God day oh my my
day my day I wish it was a [__] day
he would commit suicide yeah mine I come
in he's like you need teeth whiter M and
that might be the thing that does it
where he jumps off the Golden it's like
looking at my mouth it's like looking at
War it's a lot of work mine too if I'm
like he man I need teeth W he go M yeah
it's just it's like so overwhelming my
dentist starts to weep when he looks at
my mouth others commit suicide and I
show him my dick and he starts to laugh
all right now uh laugh I don't know what
we're saying I don't even know what's
going on I don't either hey that thing
is Tiny the American West has the
highest suicide rate the nation and has
since the frontier days it's kind of
weird I don't know why but I will say
that Seattle counts yeah uh I don't know
if Seattle counts Seattle c west yeah
specific Northwest I think the West
would be considered Noe I think the West
would be considered um Utah Colorado
those areas are more the West um Wyoming
Montana that would be considered the
American West really I believe so and
maybe you could look up what the
American West Midwest that's the it midw
not the Midwest Midwest would be Chicago
and places like that um can you look up
the the highest death rates uh occup
occup well check this out the current
epidemic of suicides among white males
in the US is part of the story here in a
recent article in Salon Robert Henley
wrote according to Federal morbidity
rates stats in 1999
9,599 white men killed themselves by
2010 11 years later that number was
14,000
379 and in 2013 the US recorded
41,100
suicides 7% of which were white men why
are they does it say why how crazy is
that there are yeah and they mostly shot
themselves so they used a gun to do it
oh yeah standard American West Utah
Colorado Arizona new New Mexico yeah and
and and actually the largest uh the
largest contingency the demographic in
Middle was middle-aged white men between
the ages of 45 and 64 four that's who
killed themselves and one of the one of
the theories is that they you know they
used to be part of by default they were
at the top of the social and economic
totem pole right if you were white you
were just automatically higher status
than anybody who is a minority uh
certainly a woman and that's changing
now but also a lot of these men because
of the economy in that area are out of
work they don't feel sign they don't
feel significant anymore at 45 they feel
like this soety doesn't pay attention to
them yeah they're they used to have
power and they lost power and I at 50
you know I I'm hearing this I told you
from Comics thoughts I I don't I'm just
doing too I thought you going to go
there no no man but I've just heard a
lot about you see some Comics who are
not doing well well their fifth isn't
some people play grab ass and we we know
a lot of girls like this like there's a
hot girl and they they go on audition be
these actors or comedians or whatever
and it doesn't end working up and then
at 50 you see him at a coffee sh with
their titties down to the ground [__]
bad choice tattoos all over their body
and just never worked out that's right
and that's always a tough one it really
is man they make a mean cup of joe
though and God bless them they make a
mean Cup of Jo a mean cappuccino and
they suck don't say it don't say it out
loud the life they suck the life out of
you if you go to that coffee shop thank
you that's what I I was going to say
they make a mean cappuccino and then
they will suck the life out of you suck
the life out of you no don't say it why
you have to say dick suck your dick like
a like a corn dog on a hot summer day I
mean it is true but don't say it out
loud practice makes perfect and after 50
years and bad decisions and horrible
tattoos and one hell of a cappuccino you
learn some things well when you're one
skill you picked up in La was sucking
dick well when you're 50 and you've been
here since you were
27 you have girls I I put up some
numbers as you know I've gone through
some numbers B and I've gone through
some numbers and a lot of those numbers
when I was in my 20s and my 30s and
those girls were delicious on the
streets they call you the white Mamba
they call me the white Mamba put numers
I put up some numbers put up straight up
assassin put up points straight up [__]
assassin you understand hey man that's
not me that's don't throw that out
that's what you said I said white mama
that's another word [__] ass that's
what you just said no I called you white
Mama white Mama AKA you're dropping
snakes white Mama white snakes look I'm
not saying it it's what you said you say
when you say white Mama AKA [__]
assassin that's what you said P you it I
said you're the white
assassin cuz you're shooting ropes I'm I
shoot heavy ropes although now I'm older
and it just kind of comes out and
dribbles point we don't call you white
Mama now no we don't call kid now now I
got kid now you call me guy with guy
creepy guy with wife two kids who goes
uhhuh when hot girls come by that's not
white M you understand no oh here it is
but but but what I'm saying is what I'm
saying is that now you see those girls
now you see my girls and they're they're
my age now 48 bad bad choices bad living
at 48 50 years old and things change a
little bit hey I want to apologize
everyone with the again I don't check
check fact at all I don't fact check
that's why we have chin uh so the number
one job of suicide these days apparently
mine was in 1990 let time I checked uh
but if you're in farming fishing
forestry American West 85% of suicides
there you go 80 80 85 suicide for every
100,000 people that's a lot a lot
Construction coming in second and by the
way sorry I'm sorry but those Industries
have suffered a great deal of they have
there a lot of those jobs have gone away
especially construction farming uh
forestry again in the west and and
predominantly used to be white males you
know who occupied those positions not a
lot of black Farmers sir insulation
maintenance repair also production
production architect engineering
Protective Services I get that it's a
dark
art design Entertainment Sports media
how you going to just chunk all art
design Entertainment Sports athletes
media these things are tough number
seven not not as a farmer it's not tough
they are
[__] Library workers lowest rate lest
yeah because that's a fun job Li you put
me in a library and I have to be like
this [__] I thought Library I'll shoot
myself be top five Library worker but
maybe they're just balls deep in being
quiet and just dressing like that
cardigan you had on my this is my
impression of a librarian sh sh watch
ready look it up look it
up sh uh fiction watch Isle seven watch
ready this book is late this book is
late sh look it up remember remember
finds if you didn't turn your book in
one time what the [__] [__] you it's
like vide tapes [__] you gotbust lot of
dude I remember and my mom was just as
bad as me my brother and I would rent
stuff or my mom we'd rent movies and we'
come back like you owe
$275 and we like God dog never mind buy
the movie we would hustle oh yeah you
might as well we' like listen is there
any way you can just let us get these
and the next time come in pay for it and
the guy like I guess like yes thank God
sometime like there's nothing we can do
you get a bill I get late bills I would
forget they'd be like this is going to
cost $25,000 I'm afraid that we have to
repossess your house how ridiculous was
that they like you owe $700 I'm like for
[__] yeah for Terminator 2 I can I'll
just buy it why it should
after have it done as a play how no [__]
there's no more Blockbuster cuz after 30
days if I don't return it just charge me
for the movie let me keep it correct
[__] you guys correct God vidiots which
is an amazing video store on Pico and
Fourth Street in Santa Monica famous
it's got every movie still there yeah
it's where all when you would go there
it would be all like you'd see famous
directors was where all the real film
Buffs would go it still is still got a
cult following but you if you if you
were I mean You' get it on Thursday you
better bring it back that Saturday cuz
couple days late and they're going to
repossess your house you'd lose your
[__] car you'd be like what what's
going on sorry late videos all I get
myself a nice pack of Red Vines I'd pick
out probably a movie I've seen a hundred
times yeah and go home and just balls
deep in that movie what is the movie
you've seen the
most um probably uh there's a few of
them there's like Billy Masson Happy
Gilmore Dumb and Dumber uh Ace Ventura
and then all the Arnold movies I've seen
I was so ballsed deep in Arnold even cut
my hair in a flat top and uh and then
Blood Sport really Blood Sport Arnold
movies John CLA vanam then Adam Sandler
Jim Carrey movies though that's kind of
the stable there amazing even today if
it's on I'll watch them you ever seen
Monty Python the Holy Grail I have yeah
I was I was a little too young for that
even to appreciate what it is go and get
that on your belt again yeah get that
under your belt yeah I like that yeah
and get a book called Catch 22 under
your belt another great book to read a
couple books you got to get on your belt
Fahrenheit what is it yeah we're talking
about movies right now okay we're
talking about movies and got get your 51
your was it fhe what was it 51 521 what
is it I can't remember anyway it's B I
have no idea was a [__] book they made
us read in middle school so so
prophetic uh T
451 yeah [__] you they misreading Middle
School is that the the I think that's
the that I believe that's the
temperature a book Burns at or something
crazy I can't remember great book R
that's right the late bra Bradberry
great writer yeah maybe I'll scour over
that one when I have nothing to do
before I commit like it because in the
book there's a dog there's a no I read
Ito a robotic we had to read in school
there's a robotic dog there's a robotic
dog that can find you and it and it
pierces you with a with a sleeping
potion it's got this long needle that
comes out and it's just basically a dog
that can find you and run way faster of
course and he's made a steel most
listener you know that you have read in
school yes yeah yeah classic the
negative connotation censorship anyways
uh you got anything else Chin Chin no
I'm good no fan questions today no fan
questions today when this comes out
you're going to be in Austin Texas I'm
going to be in Austin Texas Cap City
godamn Tom well when you guys are
hearing this I'll be there tonight
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
bringing heat you are bringing heat as
usual and then the firing kit is live
next week in San Francisco cobs Comedy
Club Thursday and Friday pretty sure
Thursday is sold out there are tickets
left for Friday but that [__] is
selling well too tat
k.com the big brown breakdown is sold
out as of right now at the ice house um
so there you go tk.com go see Brian
Austin go see both of us in San
Francisco next week Thursday Friday this
is the 9th and the 10th in San Francisco
this is the final kid we're out